[Music]  [Applause]  dr. su Varma's hirsute you were here we  just heard from Jane Pauley and Kurama  why it's important for celebrities and  well-known people to speak out when  celebrities speak out two big things  happen number one is we pay attention  because we pay attention to people that  we like and that we respect and we get  educated and informed and number two we  realize that they're not two camps of  people they're not people with mental  illness and then successful people  successful people often live with mental  illness so this can very much be a part  of our lives and we can thrive and still  be dealing with issues at the same time  they normalize and mainstream the  congressmen all right super arm is going  to stay where's the head  [Applause]